i've been pretty honest about this my
favorite thing to watch on tv at night
true crime documentaries i'm not the
only one they're very popular
but through this whole long year of
quarantine
i've noticed something a lot of these
popular true crime documentaries
um they're really really long right they
come in many many many many many parts
and you watch them then you realize they
didn't shed any new light
on an old crime and so i've been getting
disappointed
and even though i was excited to hear
that netflix has another true crime
series coming out
i watched the trailer for it i'm
i'm sorry i'm skeptical check it out
some murders are never solved
this is not one of them
or is it we'll let you be the judge of
that
in this investigative documentary series
about a grisly string of crimes in the
1970s
infamously known as the open and shut
murders
true crime experts called it a homicide
detective's dream
and a lot of paperwork sure but pretty
unremarkable in every other way
murder wise but what did they miss
we'll keep digging until every theory is
debunked every shred of evidence is
unearthed
and every piece of stock footage is
exhausted
even ones that don't make a lot of sense
you'll see the same old photos several
times but shot in different ways
because we came up a little short on
archival material
hear from experts i didn't work that
case
then hear from non-experts did anyone
stop to consider that maybe these people
were killed by a dracula or
hear me out draculas
then hear from more experts but ones
that are not especially relevant to this
subject
well we were doing tusk for fleetwood
mac mick had me recorded making all
kinds of crazy drum sounds he's
banging on floor toms kleenex boxes at
one point he's holding up a lamb chop
and hitting it with a spatula
uh anyway uh sorry about your murders
killing time the easily solved mystery
of the opening shut murders
a two hour film stretched out across 16
one-hour episodes